what I try to do at the end of this is
take all the different points of view
side conversations and and find some
synthesis and major themes that have
gone on why we've discussed this and
I'll talk a little bit so I don't forget
addressing Joey's provocation after
Joyce's question which is around kind of
mapping what's going on it's something
that we've really looked at and tried to
figure out is it a Salesforce solution
whatever but we recently did
conversations with all of our active
grantees and many of our active
prototypes are first class of prototype
grants and we're asking them you know
what kinds of things can I do better
what you need from us what we heard over
and over again that this type of thing
this type of convening is vitally
important to it and we found that people
were reticent to talk to each other if
they hadn't physically met before so
once you find that there's something
here that's very special that we're very
focused on and saying how do we be very
strategic about these convenings are how
do we do signal the noise right when you
have someone when you meet someone how
the best thing to do is think about how
you can follow them how you can keep in
touch with them but we know that the
physical connection for that is really
important and after that it becomes
easier to do that mapping the entire
universe of what's going on it's
difficult but I think if we get better
at thinking about this for convening and
what I heard from everyone that I talked
to was that that was really important so
just a little bit of an answer to that
and why this is so important how these
ideas that we have so this is one of the
things that came out for me on this is a
lot of this stuff that we're talking
about there's a real disconnect and it's
something that you might have heard and
something I said which is to say that a
lot of conversation about the open web
only occurs on Sand Hill Road and K
Street and usually oppositional e so how
do we move this how do we make it
something that you run into that you're
perhaps
sick of seeing as I mean as a format so
I think one of the things to talk about
that's a continuing conversation that
came up increasingly in our thoughts
during this conference was why isn't
this something that's more important to
everyone and we addressed it a little
bit
and I'll go through some of those so
first of all being open might not be
enough it might not be enough to pat
ourselves on the back and say while
we're doing all this open stuff and it's
a great and it is great but increasingly
what we found in what is I think a
conversation here is when you produce
these things that are beneficial and
positive for our culture country world
you're really at a brand warfare moment
with the rest of content on the planet
so what used to be where you're if
you're developing a truth-telling app
that's a brand you have to think of it
as a brand really because what you're
going up against is the Walking Dead and
Game of Thrones you're not going up
against another truth-teller app you're
not going into another media site it's
the flow of information so high how do
we make these things how do they get
attention paid to them so opening your
being open is key it's vital as a
cornerstone but I think what we heard is
how do we extend that how do we push
that how do we make sure that once it's
open and that it is open how do we build
community around that really important
this came up a lot and what I mean by
think water not plumbing is we tend to
talk about the pipes we tend to talk
about the infrastructure the fight for
us is often around making sure that
these things aren't even the metaphors
that we use tend to be around Fastlane
slow lane you know these kind of systems
idea when really what we heard over and
over again is the thing that turns
people is content right when something I
get eliminated from something when I
can't see something when I want to do it
that's when I realize there's
constrictions on what we're doing so we
have to think shift the conversation to
being a lot more about water and what
type of water we have and why that water
is important or perhaps beer but not
necessarily what the plumbing is for it
and that's going to be really important
as we move forward and this tension
around making these types of issues much
more open this I think came up a lot I
don't think we know who we have some
ideas who are important in these spaces
and have been but I think we have to
make sure that we're finding new heroes
and celebrate them large and small
technical non-technical this morning
around we saw a lot of people like that
and with the
examples in Turkey of people taking
opportunities to be working in very
heroic ways around journalism openness
fairness those types of things finding
them celebrating them moving them to the
forefront I think is going to be really
vital so a recurrent thing that's
happened in this conference is the need
to remember the human we just had a
great example of that with human
centered design a brief overview of that
in this last couple of hours but there's
a sense that there's all this machinery
going on and I think it was especially
with a city in the censer moment where
you're losing the sense of what the
human is and making sure the human is
centered into this so that as we talk
about these issues it's easy to forget
that there's people behind it and that
the the notion that there's something
behind there and that the technology is
overriding what it is about humans that
humans are using it technology and
that's what they're about is I think
really important to keep in mind and so
that they're not ghosts they're actually
humans right so there's actually
something there and we need to pay
attention to all the time you need to be
building for we need to think about we
need to interact with and it's not the
tech or software itself I was really
struck by this and again this notion how
do we make all these differentials more
democratic the notion of a grandmother
in Turkey changing the DNS it's a great
I it's great and I'm gonna you think
about that it's like how can we have we
make those types of skillsets ubiquitous
how do we enable people to understand
the Internet in that way and thinking
about that that's so vital to do and
it's so important in their lives that
they will figure out or look up or find
someone else to help them do that and we
need a lot more I think again on this
notion of democratizing a lot of these
issues across so it's not just
specialists it's not just people in this
room that care about it but actually
people everywhere what came up a lot I
think weirdly is that we need more
policy people we don't have a lot of
policy people actually even here and
these are issues
that need people we need to start
interfacing with that just as a lot of
what Knight has done and what we have
tried to do with the MIT conference is
an interface technologists and
developers with journalism with
information and what those things are
and I think what we're increasingly
running up against is the need to do
that and governing bodies we find we do
a lot of open government work or a
little bit we try to do open government
work over and over again it's the things
that you heard throughout the conference
that it's a leadership at the top that
defines the time and space that allows
those changes to occur and we need a lot
more people in those so there's new
heroes that we have we have to find them
I think in the walks so and so another
aspect of what we have is how do we
layer those people into government with
these issues that we care about how do
we interface with those how do we give
them tools to do it it's amazing when we
start getting into open government
people will say you know this is I don't
know if it's legal for me to give you
this spreadsheet they have no idea it's
not that they don't want to and they
just don't have any aspects of it and
Jim Pocket tells this great story from
Code for America where she said you know
I'd go into a city and I said well why
don't we release this database and they
say well it's against the law and she's
like okay well show me the law and then
they can't find the law and they said
well it's actually a policy and she goes
okay well find me the policy right and
they try to find the policy and there is
no policy and he's like well there's
probably a memo and you know okay well
find me the memo right and then they get
sounding it's like Doug said we're not
supposed to do it right and then like
Doug hasn't worked there for five years
okay so so we need to figure out how to
get those people in and really work and
help them get the strategies around that
so this is the coin net term a coin I
turned a coin which is getting at the
tensions between what we talked about
with the potential of what urban spaces
is and what sensors and surveillance and
that so a combination of this very
connected complex thing that is utopia
and panopticon at the same time right so
something in this notion that the sensor
networks that we have could build brave
new cities that are really exciting at
the same time what does it mean for the
individual what does it mean for us to
surveillance what does it mean for
freedom and these are things that I
think we really have they're conjoined
and weird and we have to unpack it and
not that I think this is going to enter
the dictionary anytime soon
but the notion is how how do we think
about these things in really smart ways
and how do we pay attention to it and
not block the things that are going on
so one final mean moment which is to say
this is something I that was heard over
and over again and not that I want to
leave on a pessimistic note but because
I think a lot of the conference has been
optimistic around these things but it's
very real I think all of a sense that at
this 25-year turn of the internet
anniversary that there's a real
potential of losing many of the things
that we've worked a lot of us our whole
lives on building and vigilance is key
on this and I think if if we're active
in it we can get through it but being
very aware of the mark sermon of saying
I think we're losing is scary so these
kind of convenings and having everyone
interact is super important and these
are the kinds of things that if we have
more of these and we stay in contact and
we develop more ideas and we think
refreshed in the new we won't have to
worry about this other than making sure
that we're vigilant and what's going on
so even did an amazing job of thinking
everyone I would also like to thank you
and a big thing you again to Laurie and
Ethan and Laird in city 125 for coming
thank you all for coming here and just a
final shout out I have to say to Megan
if she would stand up a bit because
[Applause]
and and the reason for that is Friday's
actually make his last day at the knight
foundation so she's she's leaving for a
terrific opportunity to very great
nonprofit as a project manager in Miami
but will miss her desperately I know you
all will miss her desperately when these
things happen she's just been an amazing
person to work with so just on that note
good luck to Megan
thanks to all of you and we'll see you
on the Internet
[Applause]